Apple has done it again or have they the
company posted a record third-quarter
profit of ten point seven billion
dollars but if you think it was all from
the Apple watch I don't think anybody
thinks that but if you think that think
again in fact apples keeping their lips
tight on just how many of the watches
they've actually sold Bloomberg's tim
higgins who cover his apples joins us
from San Francisco with more Tim apples
watch is what most people were watching
in terms of growth for the company Tim
Cook said the launch was as good as the
launch for the actual iPad we have any
idea how many watches they actually sold
yeah well they wouldn't give a unit
number they suggested last year that
they wouldn't do this so this is not a
surprise yeah we can still kind of back
out where some of the new revenue came
from maybe 909 hundred and fifty million
dollars a new revenue coming in and if
you if you divide with the average
selling price that it's been estimated
by analysts that could potentially be at
least 2 million watches and the quarter
maybe 2.5 million as some analysts are
estimating we talked so much about China
being a massive opportunity for Apple if
the Chinese economy continues to slow
down is that going to have huge impact
or is the opportunity set so big there
it doesn't actually matter yeah but if
you look at the results this past
quarter I double it it revenue doubled
in China that's definitely where the
growth is occurring a lot of the growth
is occurring for Apple they expect you
to eventually become there one other day
or largest market in the world
overtaking the US so a slowdown would
not be the best timing travel
nevertheless the company says they there
you have full confidence in the in
what's going on in the country that
macro environment they think is is prime
for continued growth going forward and
the other argument that's going on for
Apple in China is that the the price
points of the phone are appealing to
folks that have more money to spend you
know Tim we started off the segment
asking about the Apple watch because
everybody is trying to figure out what
the next growth story for Apple is in
the meantime Apple is essentially an
iphone company they are getting seventy
percent of their operating income from
the Apple do you ever worry that the
company is actually too dependent I want
product well it's kind of a classic at
apple store you used
the butt of the revenues were coming
from the mac and then a then it was the
ipod and then and then the i now it's
the iphone and it's one thing that the
apples really kind of been consistent
about is that they will cannibalize
whatever hit product ahead in the past
for the next new one so the question is
what is the new one going to be and
that's kind of what you see quarter
after quarter is they hit these big
numbers analysts and investors are
saying well what's the next thing coming
down down the road and for them in the
interim and in the next few years it's
clearly going to be the iphone there was
hope that the I the Apple watch would
help kind of level some of that take
some of the pressure off but clearly
it's not happening just yet it's going
to be looks to be a slow kind of build
up some analysts thinking is going to be
at least another 18 months before we
really see if the watch is taking off
but does the next iPhone have to be this
grand reveal with huge new upgrades and
new you know new apps within it people
are in the Apple ecosystem millions and
millions of people and they don't want
out because there are seventy percent of
Apple phone users who haven't upgraded
isn't it doesn't it seem somewhat
obvious that a huge slug of them are
simply going to upgrade because they're
in the Apple family yeah exactly there
is a little bit of utility element to
where Apple is becoming some investors
in analysts have kind of talked about
this is essentially becoming it almost a
utility or an annuity company where
these kind of customers are keep going
out and that's why Apple's spending so
much time trying to develop out some of
its services such as Apple music and
Apple pay the question is continued
growth the growth beyond just the apple
of enthusiasts yeah Tim one thing that
stuck out to me from the call was Tim
Cook actually said they are seeing the
highest Android switcher rate that they
have ever seen that sounds great but i
don't think i have ever heard tim cook
acknowledged that he is looking in his
rearview mirror I feel like Steve Jobs
would never ever have acknowledged
another company not breathed their name
not think they're not utter a syllable
that sounded like anything else what you
make of it well this is at this point
this is Tim Cook's company
and he has been the CEO for a number of
years and it really the the introduction
of the watch and the largest screen
iPhones really was his imprint here on
the company in the past year he's really
kind of come into his own made the
company that the executive team is
behind him and he is definitely plotting
kind of the future here so that you use
you don't think he's worried for the
first time ever hey with with the record
profits this year you know I think that
they I think that you could almost 10
business and some frustration that
people weren't excited for what they
were producing indeed and that would be
very very fair every other company in
the world would be thrilled with this
they are literally growing money on
trees no actually literally they're not
Olivia I think all right it's definitely
a girl your penis honest thank you so
much tim higgins joining us there from
san francisco